the unofficial start to summer travel
season that would be memorial day is
less than two weeks away so how about an
early travel report first off get your
wallets ready gas prices hit another
record high at more than four dollars
and fifty cents a gallon and get your
patients ready 39 million americans are
expected to travel 50 miles or more from
home that is up 8 over the prior year
and it includes 3 million people who
will fly that is a giant 25 increase
from last year and speaking of travel i
have traveled back to the table because
we got a big guest here well done by the
way thank you very much yes our big
guest is united airlines ceo very well
done by the way right ceo scott kirby
joins us now with more on the start of
the summer vacation season we always
like to have you in the studio mr kirby
so good to have you back at the table so
you just heard it the gas prices are
going up travel's going up
more passengers staffing shortages with
the pilots with tsa agents is united
airlines ready and i know you're going
to say yes
are you really ready scott kirk we
really are ready uh at united you can
book with confidence at united but it
partly means we're not flying as big a
schedule as we were before covert we're
about 13 smaller than we were that
really is about prioritizing operating
reliability for customers over the
possibility of short-term profits but
we're going to gradually ramp up but
that's the key to making sure we're
ready is don't get out over our skis and
ahead of what the system can support
right now i think we all expected a gas
and uh gas increase because everybody's
feeling that right but the gas prices
rose the airfare prices rose 18.6
in april that's a huge jump in one month
yeah so really but price is not gas
prices yeah it really is about jet fuel
prices our jet fuel at today's prices
our fuel expense would be 10 billion
more than it was in 2019 jet fuel prices
have almost doubled in the past couple
of months and that's really driving the
price increases for airlines but why
don't you eat those prices and let the
customers benefit because we can't
afford to
look we're really we're but it's a
series
i know but we're in the recovery mode uh
from from covid and you know trying to
come out of what was the most
devastating crisis in the history of
aviation uh we've got to get back we
made it we survived through the crisis
but now at united we took on an extra 22
billion dollars of debt we got to start
paying that down and so we've at least
got to recover the increase in jet fuel
prices but you are expecting record
numbers this quarter correct well we're
expecting record revenues uh this
quarter but our profitability is still
lower than it was in the pre-covered era
because fuel prices have gone up so much
so we haven't quite recovered all the
fuel price yet um so we are eating some
of it but uh but prices are going up
really because of depth price yeah the
tsa is warning of some hiccups for
staffing shortages of their own i got to
say thank you to heidi from detroit who
let me cut the line all the way up to
my flight to detroit yesterday i'm
serious or to buffalo yesterday and all
the passengers are talking about you
tony i i don't care i had a pose for
some pictures thank you to heidi and
everyone else in that line uh that was
my on me uh but you know that's slightly
outside of your lane but you know should
people be prepared for extra delays when
they get to the airport as well yeah
look there there are staffing shortages
across the whole economy that affects
the tsa and others around airlines i
think the tsa by the way has done a
great job uh throughout the crisis and
they do things like you talked about you
know helping customers that are going to
miss a flight not just because you're a
tv star they do it for people every day
and all the time
but i would get to the airport a little
earlier this summer because staffing
store and staffing shortages are
exacerbated you know somebody gets
covered then everyone tests and
you know the sick calls are higher in
all businesses than they were before and
so probably get to the airport a little
bit earlier than you normally would just
because of the possibility we've talked
about this before but it just logically
scott doesn't make sense to me that we
don't have to wear a mask on the plane
honestly i mean we're in this little
tube and i know you're going to talk
about air circulation i was on a plane
the other day i was coughing i didn't
have cover but people looked at me like
i slapped their mama and i realized and
i had my mask on but it just
helped me understand why it's okay to
fly with that many people who are
coughing and doing whatever why that is
still safe well first our customers that
they want can absolutely wear a mask but
the reason it's safe on an airplane it
literally is the safest environment
you're going to be indoors anywhere that
you are it's because the airflow on
airplanes was designed to recirculate
every two to three minutes through hepa
grade filters the second best place you
can be is a hospital icu the airplane is
literally 10 times more airflow through
hypograde filters than a hospital icu
that's why an airplane being on an
airplane next to two people in a middle
seat is the equivalent of being 15 feet
away from someone in a building you're
safer sitting next to me on an airplane
than you are sitting across the table
from me right now scott we've been
talking over the last couple of weeks
about the possibility of roe v-8 being
overturned
and you know i find that nowadays
politics and business are somewhat
synonymous do you feel like it's an
obligation to step in when these issues
arise for your employees so i my
obligation i think is is to do the right
thing for our employees our recent
advertising campaign is good leads the
way we've tried to do the right thing
throughout
my preference is to lead by example the
work that united has done on
sustainability on diversity even what we
did with vaccine requirements that was
controversial but we took action instead
of talking let action lead the way and
do the right thing for for our employees
and our customers well you said it used
to be fly the friendly skies something
special in the air now it's good leads
away but
according to a recent survey united
airlines came in below average for
customer satisfaction what are you doing
or need to do to change that so we are
uh we're working to improve the customer
satisfaction all of our internal data
actually some of those are backwards
looking and particularly during covet
our internal data says that we have the
highest net promoter scores in in our
history but what we're doing all kinds
of things to run the airline reliably to
communicate with customers we're getting
better about like yesterday there were
huge storms here in new york telling
customers in advance what's going on you
can't avoid that they're going to be
weather issues but communicating with
customers investing in the experience
and the product on the airplane there's
a long list of things and we see the
data internally that's backwards looking
but you look forward that it really is
changing at united how customers feel
when they fly nate race a good point
about companies that are starting to
speak out about controversial political
issues do you intend to speak out
publicly about these issues uh you know
i
when we need to we will
we have tried however to really focus on
letting action lead the way you know one
of the frustrations i think we all have
with politics it's become divisive
people are against the other side as
opposed to four things yeah we can do
things like the aviate academy which is
training the next generation of pilot
but it's also affecting diversity that's
inspirational to people it's positive
lead by positive example um and there's
a lot of opportunities for us in
corporate leadership to lead by positive
example instead of just be putting out a
corporate statement that's opposed to
something i hear you on that i enjoy my
united flights by the way thank you
scott thank you so much we will be right
back